today on the matt walsh show democrats
declare total war
on reality passing the equality act
which seeks to legally erase women and
give delusion
precedence over reality also five
headlines including rand paul's
brilliant and bold questioning
of a hhs nominee who supports drugging
and mutilating gender confused children
and another race hoax exposed but not
before lives were ruined because of it
in our daily cancellation we will
discuss the plight of mr potato head who
is struggling to decide whether he is
gender fluid or not all of that
and much more today on the matt wall
show
before we get going today i want to tell
you about our very good friends at rock
auto
you know the thing with rock auto is
they're going to save you time and money
there's no reason to be going to the
auto parts store if you have any car
trouble if you need anything
no reason to go to the auto parts store
and spend all your time there
spend more money than you need to you
could just go to rockauto.com you have
access to rockauto.com
uh with you that you carry around in
your pocket you know you carry
rockauto.com around in your pocket maybe
you didn't know that
you can use your phone uh or or sit at
your desk on your laptop rockauto.com
always offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices
uh or you know basically trying to milk
you for all your worth they're not going
to do that
um and rockauto.com is what i really
like it's a family business they've
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
and you have the peace of mind of
knowing if you find it on rock auto
whatever you're looking for
you're most likely going to find it in
rockauto.com and you also can know that
you're getting the best price you don't
need to look anywhere else this is the
best price you can possibly get
the rockauto.com catalog is unique very
easy to navigate that's a comment that i
hear a lot from
people that go to the website it's
really easy to find your way
around and you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available
for your car or truck and remember to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you when john
money the 20th century psychologist
pedophilia apologist
and all-around quack first invented the
concept of gender identity several
decades ago
he probably couldn't imagine that the
democrat party would one day
enshrine his half-baked crazy ideas into
law
back when money was running sexual
experiments on young boys having them
strip on camera simulate
sex acts on each other and forcing one
to live as a girl against his will
it would have seemed like a pipe dream
that in the not too distant future
his ideas his theories about biological
sex and
gender being two somehow distinct and
valid forms of identity
would be legislatively imposed on the
american population
and when his two human experiments
eventually went on to kill themselves
i'm sure money might have feared that
his theories would end up on the
proverbial ash heap of history but
that's not what happened now the good
doctor who died 15 years ago can
look up from wherever he is and i have
some theories about where that might be
and feel proud that although the concept
of gender identity is
nonsensical and incoherent and though
his attempt to scientifically prove the
validity of his theories ended with the
suicides of two people
still his ideas won the day and soon the
entire country will be forced by law to
live according to them
so the so-called equality act was passed
by the democrat-controlled house of
representatives on thursday moves now to
the democrat-controlled senate
the law is a sweeping and radical
assault on religious liberty women
children
moral decency sanity it is indeed the
most
serious legislative attack on women's
rights in american history
as it seeks to legally erase women in a
way and to an extent that
not even the most dastardly and
misogynistic agent of the patriarchy
could have ever dreamed the people were
who were worried that mike
pence would bring handmaid's tale to
life were the whole time
working to establish their own dystopia
that goes far beyond anything that
margaret atwood conceived
the bill has other significant
consequences too as our own ian howerth
explains for the daily wire the equality
act sets to sets the stage to dismantle
religious liberty
he writes in a recent article quote the
equality act would expand protection
against discrimination
provided by the civil rights act such as
employment and housing to also cover
federally funded programs and public
accommodations which include retail
stores online retailers
stadiums transportation service
providers etc as an example
this would mean that businesses targeted
discrimination suits for refusing
certain services based on religious
objections
would be impacted by the equality act
such as florists or bakeries
the equality act would also supersede
the religious freedom restoration act
passed in 1993 which quote set a higher
bar for the government to defend laws
if people argued those laws infringed
upon religious freedom
now the act also obliterates conscience
protections for those who don't want to
fund or perform abortions
alexandra de sanctis in national review
lays out the details she writes
under the equality act healthcare
professionals will be required by
law to perform sex reassignment
procedures or offer hormone replace
or offer related hormone treatment even
if such procedures contradicted their
own best medical judgment
so too the law would treat refusals to
perform an abortion as pregnancy
discrimination
which would be treated as an illegal
form of discrimination on the basis of
sex
the equality act redefines sex to
include pregnancy childbirth
or a related medical condition and as
the bill's opponents have noted
federal agencies and courts have already
determined that the phrase related
medical condition
can be interpreted to include abortion
this is all quite horrifying on its own
but it isn't even the most extreme
consequence of the bill
worst of all the civil rights act of
1964 would be updated to include sexual
orientation and gender
identity as protected classes on the
same level as race
the text of the bill reads in part quote
an individual shall not be denied access
to a shared facility including a
restroom
a locker room and a dressing room that
is in court in accordance with that
individual's
gender identity in fact as already noted
this mandate would apply to all public
accommodations and conveniently enough
pretty much
everything counts or can count as a
public accommodation
your home does appear to be exempt at
the moment but the democrats i'm sure
will not let that loophole remain for
very long
what this means is that if this law
passes it will be it will it will be
effectively illegal to provide
any private or exclusive spaces to women
bathrooms sports teams locker rooms all
of these must
by law be opened to any man who demands
access
under the equality act the government
would not recognize woman
as being a necessarily distinct category
from men
all that matters is a person's gender
identity
this raises an important question what
the hell
is gender identity well
it's not really anything in particular
it's an entirely invented artificial
concept originating
originating with the child abusing quack
mentioned earlier
that's probably best defined if it can
be defined at all
by the human rights campaign which is a
fervent and influential proponent of the
equality act hrc says on the sexual
orientation and gender identity
definitions page of their website that
gender identity is
quote one's innermost concept of
self as male female a blend of both or
neither
how individuals perceive themselves and
what they call themselves one's gender
identity can be the same or different
from their sex assigned at birth
let us try to wrap our heads around the
sheer
lunacy here your biological sex
is what you actually are your true
sexual identity
as determined by immutable physical
characteristics
your gender identity is what you feel
like
you are or what you want to be or how
you perceive yourself
under the equality act one's perception
of themselves even if
incorrect takes precedence over the
reality
of what they actually are
the reality is no longer legally
recognized at all in fact
delusion and fantasy supplant officially
truth falsehood wins the day
of course female sports teams never had
anything to do with self-perception it
makes
absolutely no difference what a male
thinks or how he feels about himself or
how he feels about anything
none of that changes his biological
features which give him an unfair
advantage over females
and though the male may feel like he was
supposed to have a vagina whatever the
hell that means
the reality is that he has the same
equipment as any other male and belongs
in the same locker rooms and bathrooms
as those other males
the sign on the bathroom door says or
said
men and women not those who feel like
men today
and those who feel like women today
that's the only sensible and coherent
way to organize these things
based on what actually is
not how you feel it's also the only way
that provides women with the privacy and
protection they need
but sensibility and coherence are soon
to be illegal
it doesn't take much imagination to see
where this goes if self-perception is
more important than reality
if in fact self perception is our new
reality
then there's no reason whatsoever to
limit that standard to gender
i mean what about a white man who seeks
the advantages
of of affirmative action in college
admissions on the basis that he
perceives himself to be black
it might be crazy to accept that a white
man is a black man just because he sees
himself that way but it's still quite a
bit less crazy
than accepting that a male is a female
on the same basis
what about a pedophile who perceives
himself to be nine years old
again it makes no sense to give his
perception of his own
age legal precedence over the reality of
his actual age
but it's certainly no more senseless
than doing the same in the realm of
biological sex
any argument for giving gender identity
protected status
would apply absolutely to age identity
race uh to age identity race identity or
anything else
as always the left will scoff at what
they will call
a slippery slope argument and then in a
few years they will do exactly what they
mocked us for predicting they would do
that's the way these things always work
and will most assuredly work in this
case
the democrats have declared total war on
reality
and we haven't even begun to reap the
consequences
now let's get to our five headlines
before we get to our five headlines i
want to tell you about paint your life
you know one thing i've
i've learned especially after getting
married
and and uh and having a woman in the
house i i've learned a little bit
about how to you know i i still not the
one who does the decorating
my wife does all of that but i picked up
a few tips and tricks
along the way and one thing i've
certainly learned is that you need
some great paintings on the wall that's
what's going to bring the whole room
together it's going to elevate it
it gives it that real sort of homey feel
that you want
and that's why you need to go to
paintyourlife.com if you want it to give
a truly meaningful
gift to someone else or to yourself
you've got to try paint yourlife.com you
can get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo
at a truly affordable price choose from
a team of world-class artists and work
with them until every detail is perfect
uh it's a very user-friendly platform it
lets you order a custom-made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes
and it's less than five minutes but
you're still choosing every last thing
that you want for the painting
you could be as specific as you want to
be it's a quick and easy process
you get a hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks well all you gotta do is
just send any picture it's a picture of
yourself your children your family a
special place
a pet anything at all any picture that
you have photograph
and they will turn it into a priceless
work of art
makes the perfect birthday anniversary
wedding gift or again a great gift for
yourself
speaking of which we are um going to be
getting another
we have one painting from paint your
life and my wife and i were talking
we definitely want to get another one uh
because we were so impressed with it
and so now it's just a matter of kind of
it's fun you know you go through some of
the pictures that you have and you
decide
which picture would you like to convert
into this uh work of art to put on the
on the wall so we're in the process of
doing that right now at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
will be refunded guaranteed and right
now is a limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping to get a special offer
text the word matt to 64 000
that's matt to sixty four thousand text
matt to sixty four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most
terms apply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms again
text keyword matt so rachel levine
the male health secretary of
pennsylvania who identifies as a female
and who headed up the pandemic response
in in that state which was
clumsy and disastrous and led to
thousands of elderly deaths in nursing
homes like in new york
uh pennsylvania also sent
infected people into nursing homes on
purpose just like new york did
but we're going to reward this person
with a position
um just purely on the basis of
of identity politics of course rachel
levine
had a hearing in the senate on thursday
and at least one senator stepped up
that would be rand paul to take him to
task for
his support of drugging and mutilating
gender confused children
a position that would be totally
disqualifying in a sane and healthy
country you know
it's it's if you have that position
where you're in favor of drugging and
mutilating
confused children um
that should qualify you for a mental
institution or prison
not for a position in government
but as we've been talking about this is
this is we're looking at the
enshrinement of insanity
a war on reality which is what the
democrats have been waging for some time
now
that's nothing new so uh rand paul
questioned levine and um couldn't get a
straight answer but let's let's watch
some of this let's
let's watch rand paul at least make an
attempt
you know give it the old college try to
get an answer out of rachel levine
uh where when it comes to you know
mutilating children
and what should the policy be with
gender confused children here it is
let's watch
dr levine you have supported both
allowing minors to be given hormone
blockers
to prevent them from going through
puberty as well as surgical destruction
of a minor's genitalia
like surgical mutilation hormonal
interruption of puberty can permanently
alter and prevent secondary sexual
characteristics
the american college of pediatricians
reports that 80 to 95 percent
of pre-pubertal children with gender
dysphoria will
experience resolution by late
adolescence if
not exposed to medical intervention and
social affirmation
dr levine do you believe that minors are
capable of making such a life-changing
decision as changing one's sex
well senator thank you for your interest
in this question
transgender medicine is a very complex
and nuanced field with robust research
and standards of care that have been
developed and if i am fortunate enough
to be confirmed as the assistant
secretary of health i will look forward
to working with you
and your office and coming to your
office and discussing the
particulars of the standards of care for
transgender medicine
so this is the old uh you got to pass
the bill to find out what's in it
in this case we're being told you got
you got to confirm
the nominee to find out what they
actually think about this issue
because the response that rand paul gets
we'll play the next clip yet because he
again all right we'll play the next clip
in a second because he makes another
attempt but
the response is well why don't you
confirm me and then we'll
all come to your office and we can talk
about it no why don't you talk about it
now this is a very simple question
very easy question of course we already
know the answer to it
because we have rachel levine's previous
uh statements on this subject and he's
been very clear about it
we already know the answer to it and if
we didn't already know the answer we'd
know it now
because you know when you're asked um do
you support
genital mutilation of gender confused
children
and drugging them when you're asked that
that it's if you answer anything but
hell
no what are you crazy of course not
any answer outside of that tells me that
your real answer is yes
and you don't belong anywhere in
government or anywhere in civilized
society
this is this is one of those issues and
there are several of them
but this is certainly one where if you
ever
you know if you're more on the the
moderate in the middle kind of person
um and you you may be a little confused
about who the real bad guys are
and i'm not gonna sit here and tell you
that the republicans are heroes
courageous heroes
they're far from it um i think lan
i like rand paul i think rand paul is
great
but i'm not going to tell you
republicans are in general
there are clear bad guys though and if
you ever get confused about it
if you need to be reminded then go back
and watch this exchange again
because there is one political party
that supports drugging and mutilating
children children who are are simply
confused
as all children are it's very normal for
a child to be confused
and of course a child is going to be
confused about something like
biological sex if he's not given
explanations
you know if a child at the age of four
is you know
a four-year-old boy starts saying oh i
think i'm a girl
if at that moment
his parents and his teachers if he's in
school and
his doctors if they all say to him oh no
no
no no little johnny you're you're not a
girl you're a boy
or you could even ask him why do you why
do you say that why do you why do you
say you're a girl
that's a really simple question if you
get any kind of answer at all from the
four-year-old
i guarantee it is going to be something
along the lines of um
he likes to play with dolls and he
thinks that
that pink dresses are pretty something
like that
and because in his little four-year-old
brain you know he that's
that's what he thinks a girl is he
doesn't know he doesn't
actually know what a boy or girl is at
the age of four
or five or six they don't really
understand
what what that means so that little
child
he's that's that's all he's drawing an
association
he's noticing he's perceptive and he's
noticing that generally
uh the the people that the adults call
girls are you know they
have the pink stuff and the dolls and
everything and the the people the adult
the grown-ups call
boys they wear the blue and the darker
colors and they like trucks
and so if that four-year-old boy is
going through a phase where you know
he's a little bit more interested in the
dolls big deal who cares
fine what he's going to say is
oh i am a girl he doesn't know what that
means because he's four
what he actually means is i am
interested in these things which i
associate with girls
and sane decent adults
will respond to that by saying okay
great you want to play with a dog go
play with a doll it doesn't matter
fine you're still a boy though
the child gets that kind of response
from his parents
from you know all the adults in his life
he'll be fine
he'll he'll get over this phase of
calling himself a girl in a few weeks
if not if not right that second
but if the child is told
oh well if you say you're a girl then
maybe you are
and if he's told this by all of the
adults in his life we trust then of
course he's going to be confused
who wouldn't be
fast forward a few years and now we're
gonna drug that child
by the way another thing we'll hear this
from rand paul in a second
just so you know um when when
the left says that puberty blockers
and all these hormone treatments and
hormone pills and stuff
given to children when the left says
that that it's safe
that there are no long-term side effects
they are lying
they are lying through their teeth
either they are speaking out of
ignorance
um or they are straight up lying
because the fact is number one it is
definitely not safe
you're using this this medication off
label you're using medication that was
not made to be to be given to children
who are physically healthy
you are stunting intentionally their
normal physical growth
that is by definition not safe in terms
of all of the long-term consequences
we don't know now a rational person can
guess can assume that there are going to
be a number
of of any number of serious physical
emotional psychological long-term
effects
but in terms of the full extent of it we
don't know because this
we we are we talk about experiments
we're running experiments on a whole
generation of kids right now
we don't know what it's going to look
like in 30 years democrats will just lie
and they'll say oh it's safe we already
know it they don't know that
what they mean is well we hope it's
probably said we hope it's safe and uh
so we'll find out what we'll use these
kids as guinea pigs and we'll check back
in 30 years
see how destroyed their life their lives
are
unless they've killed themselves by then
as a as as
the rimer twins did john money's victims
all right let's go back to uh rand paul
he's makes another attempt to get an
answer out of rachel levine here it is
for most of our history we believe that
minors don't have full rights and the
parents need to be involved
so i'm alarmed that you won't say with
certainty that minors should not have
the ability
to make the decision to take hormones
that will affect them for the rest of
their life will you make a more firm
decision on whether or not minors should
be involved in these decisions
senator transgender medicine is a very
complex
and nuanced field and if confirmed to
the position of assistant secretary of
health
i would certainly be pleased to come to
your office and talk with you and your
staff
about the standards of care and the
complexity of this field
let it go into the record that the
witness refused to answer the question
the question is a very specific one
should minors be making these momentous
decisions for most of the history of
medicine
we wouldn't let you have a cut sewn up
in the er but you're willing to let a
minor take things that prevent their
puberty
and you think they get that back you
give a woman testosterone enough that
she grows a beard you think she's going
to go back looking like a woman when you
stop the testosterone
you have permanently changed them
rand paul is exactly right of course
and he got a lot of grief from the left
for calling genital mutilation genital
mutilation what the hell else do you
call it
you're taking a physically healthy
person uh
you know a girl chopping their breasts
off
what else do you call about mutilation
this is if this is a physically healthy
person
or you know a male and
doing a lot of incisions and cutting and
things to to to fashion their
their male reproductive organs to look
like
some approximation of female genitals
what
what else do you call about mutilation
this is why i like rand paul um you know
he's a little too libertarian for my
taste
on on some things but he gets the gender
issue right he gets the life issue right
a lot of libertarians don't and uh so
i'm a
big supporter of rand paul okay number
two from the new york post it says a
black student's allegations that she was
targeted for eating while black at a
private massachusetts college
were deemed unfounded according to
investigation of the incident
umo uh knute then a rising sophomore at
smith college had claimed that all she
did was
all she quote did was be black when a
gender
when a janitor called security on her
when he found her in a closed lounge in
july
2018. a 35-page investigation carried
out by an outside law firm
found no evidence of discrimination the
findings were issued in october 2018 but
not widely reported
the incident began when kanote was
inside a cafeteria dormitory that was
reserved for a summer camp program for
young children
since students were not supposed to use
the area a cafeteria worker jackie blair
reminded her of that fact but then
decided to drop the issue
a janitor was in his 60s had poor vision
then noticed a figure in the distance
eating in a closed off
lounge area and and
so school guidance calls for employees
not to confront strangers on their own
so the janitor
notified security about the person who
turned out to be konote
uh the outlet reported the janitor who
reportedly later claimed he couldn't
tell the person's gender because it was
dark
told dispatchers that there's someone
sitting there lying down in the living
room
a security officer then drove over
engaged in a polite conversation
but this woman recorded it and so she
she was where she was not supposed to be
and uh you had school
you know employees followed proper
protocol
to enforce the rules what they were
supposed to do
now you also have to keep in mind from
their perspective you know you've got a
stranger in this area where they're not
supposed to be as reserved for a summer
camp for kids
if they don't say anything and allow
that person to be there
and then you know if something happens
anything happens related to that that
person well they're gonna be in trouble
for that
you know they might be liable for that
so they enforce the rules and um
and the woman claimed that it was racism
no basis for that claim whatsoever
this is back in 2018 the media ran with
it everyone ran with it went viral
online
you may i vaguely remember this when it
first happened hearing
something like this um and of course you
know as a rational person when i first
heard the story
i immediately thought
why is there any evidence that this is
race-based at all
obviously there wasn't and um but
even so uh a lot of the people involved
with this the janitor was placed on
leave the following day
i mean people lost their jobs people
were smeared
across the media as being racists these
are normal are you talking about a
janitor at a school these are normal
working-class people
totally innocent who were smeared
libeled um you know defamed as racist
had their lives ruined had their careers
ruined
lost their jobs all because of this
all because of this lie from this
despicable person who was looking for
attention
you know for her that's all she was at
she she's at this fancy college
everything's everything's going well in
her life
her life's gonna be fine
but she wanted a little bit of attention
she wanted some attention on social
media
she wanted to get some facebook likes
and some retweets
and for that just for that sake she was
willing to destroy the lives of however
many people didn't matter to her
think about what what a sociopath you
have to be
for such little reward you're willing to
completely destroy innocent people
all right this is number three from
reuters the united
states on thursday carried out an
airstrike in syria against a structure
belonging to what has said where iran
back-backed
militia um which is an apparent response
to rocket attacks against u.s targets in
iraq well
this is you know the neocons are back in
business this
is this is the return of normalcy
normalcy is restored we're bombing
overseas again
this i guess is what it's what the left
wanted right
so congratulations you get you got what
you wanted
starting the wars in the middle east
again uh number four from the daily wire
says internet mega retailer amazon
appears to have quietly updated an
internal rule just the news reports
eliminating an exemption for books and
periodicals from its site-wide policy
against selling items that contain or
promote hate speech
so amazon appears is now
important now they haven't made as far
as i know any official announcement
about this
but it appears that they are expanding
their um their policies against hate
speech and they're now taking down books
and uh this started earlier in the week
with
um ryan t anderson and his book when
harry became sally responding to the
transgender movement
that was unceremoniously removed from
amazon
um and it looks like this is the the
beginning of
of of something you know there's there's
more yet to come
but keep in mind with with this book
when harry met
um became sally rather the ryan t
anderson book this is a very we talked
about this on the back stage if you
watch backstage episode
it's a very scholarly book um
very civil compassionate uh
you know it's a good book and this
this as ryan t anderson does if you're
familiar with his work
that's how he approaches this issue like
any issue from a scholarly really
intelligent
kind of way it's it's it's not
inflammatory at all
okay he's not like me he's not throwing
digs in there he's not being
inflammatory
he's not yelling and screaming in
written form
so if this book can be can be taken down
as hate speech
for no other reason then it presents
the other side of the argument
it simply argues against left-wing
gender theory
and that's why it was taken down
and if amazon is doing that then i mean
it's it's
game over as far as amazon goes
you know they it's not like they started
with
some fringe book
from some super inflammatory you know
fringe figure
a way off on the far right if they're
starting with ryan t
anderson that's bad news
five finally the daily wire reports in a
nine page instagram post
singer and songwriter demi lovato called
gender reveal parties transphobic
and claimed that there are boys with
vaginas and girls with penises
lovato claimed throughout the lengthy
post that transgender activists
dislike gender reveal parties because
they divert from reality quote unquote
to lovato and other activists reality is
the concept that humans are born without
any concept of gender
so she's this is a lengthy post she's
against gender reveal parties
and i i read this and i thought this is
unfortunate because now that means
now that means i guess i have to be in
favor of gender-revealed parties
i have very consistently been opposed to
gender revealed parties
not on the basis of them being
transphobic but just on the basis of
them being completely silly and
ridiculous
and also it turns out dangerous because
people are dying every year from these
from these dumb things that's the reason
i oppose them
i i think it's you don't need to we
don't need all the pageantry over the
fact that uh you know your
your child has a gender just tell people
you're having a boy great let people
know send out a text message call people
up
post it on facebook whatever you want to
do they don't need a whole party just
for that reason
that's been my take on gender reveal
parties but now that the left is coming
out
out against them for being transphobic
now i feel like as a as a contrarian
especially where the left is concerned i
have to completely change my opinion and
now you know what i'm in favor of gender
reveal parties
have gender reveal parties throw throw a
freaking parade through the street
for our next kid that's what we're gonna
do now even though i hate gender reveal
parties we're gonna have we're gonna
have a gender reveal parade
through the street floats and everything
throwing candy to the kids
just despite you
um a gender reveal party out of i don't
like gender reveal parties but i like
gender reveal parties out of spite
that's how i guess i would uh split this
this issue all right let's go now to
reading the youtube comments um
this is from jamboree johnson says matt
in september of 2019 i was actually
diagnosed with gender dysphoria
this was solved not by getting surgeries
but by going to church
and attending specialized therapies in
many states a diagnosis
is not even required to medically
transition
what are your thoughts on this well my
thoughts are number one
uh i'm you know i'm i'm grateful that
you were able to
find the actual help you needed
you were suffering from this rather than
people who will
who would contribute to that suffering
by making your dysphoria worse
uh you found actual help so i'm grateful
for that
but we're getting to a point where this
that's going to be illegal soon
you know the the therapy that the real
therapy that you went out and sought and
thankfully received
that's now considered um you know
conversion therapy
that's how that's going to be labeled
and pretty soon that's going to be
illegal
but thankfully you were able to get that
help christian says no one is
indoctrinating children
you do realize that more kids are gay
now
because there is less bigotry yes this
of course christian is the argument i've
i've i have heard this argument
um that the reason why the lgbt
numbers are skyrocketing among the
younger generations is is simply because
we're more accepting and so that means
that um
people feel
that they're able to safely come out and
express their true identities
okay but eleven and a half percent that
was the number right if i remember
correctly
eleven and a half percent gen z
identifying as bisexual are you really
gonna tell me christian do you really
think
that that is reflective of the real
numbers in the general population
that do you really think that for the
for the whole globe
all 7 billion plus people 11
or more are bisexual but most of them
don't feel comfortable to come out and
admit it
does that seem reasonable to you
of course you know the great thing about
the claim you're making is that it's
it's impossible to prove and also
therefore impossible to refute
because you're saying that there are
millions and millions of people out
there
who are really bisexual they just won't
admit it well
okay it could be the case sure
i don't see any reason to assume that i
think that is a wild assumption
with no evidence for it
i think there are much more reasonable
explanations for why we're seeing this
increase in numbers and i talked about
those explanations yesterday
and a big big one is yes that it is
trendy now
it's not merely accepted and tolerated
to be gay or bisexual or to
identify somehow uh in the lgbt spectrum
it's not just accepted and tolerated
it's it's celebrated it's a trendy thing
it is social capital that you earn in
that generation
and so yes younger people kids are
encouraged to
find a way to sort of wedge themselves
into that lgbt
uh you know somewhere into those letters
somewhere
that's why we keep adding letters onto
it right it's lgbtqia
so on and so forth keep adding letters
on because people are trying
people are desperate to be in that
acronym
john dixon says i wouldn't say the left
hates all religions except for islam
it's more accurate to say that the left
hates christianity and judaism while
loving islam and being indifferent
to all other religions well
you might be the left hates
the other right the left hates anyone
who um
is different from themselves the left
hates any ideological competition
and that's why i would say they hate all
religion except for the religions except
for the religion of leftism because it
is competition
even islam it's not that the left loves
islam
i wouldn't say that's the case at all
it's simply that they don't
feel often times as
entitled to criticize it
because of all the you know all the
intersectional
identity complications
when you think of of muslims oftentimes
these are non-white people
from from oftentimes poor regions of the
world and so
you know they don't associate it as much
with white people like they do with
christianity
even though the majority of christians
are not white either but this is how
they see it and so
they don't feel as entitled to criticize
islam but when it comes down to it i
think they hate all religions
except for their own um
and finally maximilian says is it just
me or is matt's beard turning gray at
the bottom left i
i've seen a lot of comments about the
graying in the beard i don't know if it
comes on if you can see any camera right
now
but i am so excited about it i have to
tell you i've i have been accused many
times by people of dying my beard
and uh i i of all the false accusations
that is the only one
that that really really bothers me
because it is so widely accepted
but in reality i would never dye my
beard i've been excited to go gray
my wife noticed the gray in the beard
and she said oh can i pluck that out for
you guys are you kidding me
i've been waiting for this moment the
dignified graying in the beard
very excited thank you for noticing well
we've made it to friday
and that's nearly the end of the month
we're almost there which means this is
your last
chance very last chance to take
advantage of february
february harry uh february harry those
are the deals over at beard supply
you can go to beard supply anytime
you're gonna get great deals but if you
want the best deals you got to do it
right now in in commemoration of the
sacred
holiday month-long holiday called
february if you want your beard to grow
out in style
which is exactly what beard supplies all
natural all awesome beard oils will help
you do
then you've got to go to beardsupply.com
shop their february deal today you can
buy one get another one 50
off on all of their beard oils and i can
tell you
um that you really do need the the beard
oils
another question that i always get is
matt how do you get that glorious beard
you know we know it's because you're
such a manly masculine man frankly
superior to most other men that's that's
the way the beard grows like that but
how do you
what are the finishing touches how does
it how do you how do you go from a
b-plus beard to an a-plus beard
and well it takes effort that's where
the beard oil comes in the discount is
only good for the next 48 hours though
so you'd better act fast go to
beardsupply.com and make your selection
no promo code necessary just head on
over to beardsupply.com and gents since
this is the last time of the year i can
say it
happy february now go treat yourself
to some beard oils now and um there are
so many narratives you know around
hot topic issues it's hard to keep track
of all the newest controversies the left
decides to create
hard to keep track of all the false
narratives all the falsehoods in general
so get ready for the daily wire's newest
show soon to be released it's called
debunked where ben shapiro
exposes leftist fallacies in 15 minutes
or less whether it's climate change
universal healthcare coveted policies
all of that he's putting that up versus
facts and logic
this show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members so if you aren't
already a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunk to get 25
off you don't want to miss ben so use
code debunked for 25
off today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we must
discuss mr potato head
or rather potato head um we must not
dead name potato head by calling him mr
potato head any longer
according to numerous reports on
thursday hasbro
was said to be to be dropping the mister
in order to make potato head
gender-neutral
kimberly boyd the senior vice president
of global brands at hasbro
explained the move saying culture has
evolved
kids want to be able to represent their
own experiences the way the brand
currently exists with the mr and mrs is
limiting when it comes to
both gender identity and family
structure the website fast company which
interviewed boyd went to more detail
saying
this mean the toys this means the toys
don't impose a fixed notion of gender
identity or expression
freeing kids to do whatever feels most
naturally to them a girl potato might um
might want to wear pants a boy potato
might wear earrings
hasbro will also sell boxed sets that
don't present a normative family
structure
this approach is clever because it
allows kids to project their own ideas
about gender sexuality and family onto
the toy
without necessarily offending parents
that have more conservative notions
about family
well yes we cannot force this outmoded
idea of mother and father potato heads
onto kids onto society
some children may want a potato family
with two mom potatoes or two dad
potatoes or
three mom potatoes a dad potato a
chicken sandwich in order to have the
full value meal
these are the choices that children must
be able to make this is the world that
children deserve to live in a world with
transgender potatoes
homosexual potatoes pansexual potatoes
bisexual potatoes why can't the potato
be polyamorous bisexual tri-gendered and
sometimes
dabble in a little bdsm these are all
valid expressions
valid identities and they deserve to be
represented
and that's why today i did not
originally intend to cancel hasbro or
potato head
i was going to cancel all of those all
of you who are mocking this move calling
it silly superficial ridiculous woke
virtue signaling and so on
i mean you are canceled for your lack of
a progressive worldview
for your lack of appreciation and
respect for the lived experience
of gender fluid potatoes those of us
with a more enlightened outlook saw the
potato news for the landmark occasion
that it was or
we thought that it was this story has a
twisted and tragic ending but before we
get there
i just want you to understand what this
meant to me and my family
in fact i'll never forget this i i told
my seven-year-old daughter
about the potahto head news yesterday i
came into the living room she was
sitting at the table
drawing a picture of greta thunberg and
i turned to her and i said listen
addison i need to tell you something and
she looked at me and she was a little
concerned
and she said what is it father and i
took a deep breath and i said
it's happened it's finally happened
mr potato head has come out as gender
fluid
now always remember the look on her face
she was shocked at first
but then a smile spread quietly across
her face and she started to tear up
and she said finally i had been waiting
for this day my entire life
now i can be at peace and we just hugged
each other and sobbed it was it was
beautiful
and there were so many conversations
just like this across the country a
great burden
had been lifted admittedly there was
still so much work to do mr peanut mr
clean
many fictional characters must still be
freed from their gender binary prison
mr pibb most of all pibb is already a
fluid
yet we bottle it both physically and
metaphorically
and force pig to live a lie but progress
takes time
and we were taking the first step at
least that's how it seemed
then later on thursday in the midst of
the jubilation
came the crushing blow hasbro sent out
another tweet with their with the from
their official account saying
quote hold that top your main spud mr
potato head isn't going anywhere
well it was announced today that the
potato head brand name and logo are
dropping the mister
i am proud to confirm that mr and mrs
potato head
aren't going anywhere and will remain mr
and mrs potato head
devastating and for hasbro to be so
flippant
making potato puns in the midst of a
great national crisis like this
is unconscionable one minute i thought
that bigotry had been defeated that the
patriarchy dismantled
transphobia annihilated the next we're
back in our oppressive reality
with plastic potatoes that uphold the
gender binary
i'll never forget breaking the news to
my daughter
going back into the living room found
her cradling your potato head in her
arms whispering you're free my child
you're free and i sat her down and i
said addison
a tragedy has just occurred
the potato head is still a man
hasbro duped you they duped all of us
and i broke down and i wept
and addison threw the potato across the
room began to kick me violently saying
father you lied to me you lied to me you
scum
all i could do was apologize and plead
with her it was no use i knew her life
was ruined and so was mine
so it was a roller coaster day uh it
ended by careening off the tracks and
there were no survivors emotionally
and that's why hasbro is in the end
canceled
mr potato head is cancelled and all of
you who would mock our pain
or our joy before the pain are also
canceled
how dare you how dare all of you
and that's going to give us a lot to
think about over the weekend
have a great weekend i'll talk to you on
monday godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin